un havre de paix à quelques mètres du
château de versailles bienvenue à
l'arboretum de versailles chèvreloup ce
vaste parc de 200 hectares sens 2500
espèces d'arbres venus du monde entier
l'histoire de ce lieu remonte à l'époque
de louis xiv le lien avec le château de
versailles c'est que le domaine de
chèvreloup fait partie du domaine de
versailles
à l'origine le domaine de chèvreloup
était en fait un domaine agricole qui a
été acquis par louis xiv à partir de
1685 et dans le but d'étendre son
territoire de chasse
donc c'était un domaine qui était
cultivé encore par des fermiers dans le
but de fournir des espaces pour le
gibier le site officiellement été
attribué au muséum d'histoire naturelle
en 1922 mais ce n'est que dans les
années 1960 qu'il devient officiellement
un arboretum
le public pourra le visiter pour la
première fois en 1979
aujourd'hui les curieux peuvent observer
l'intégralité du site et y découvrir des
arbres de toutes tailles
c'est bien mais est-ce parce que le
sapin à noël qu'on a classiquement dans
les maisons donc un épicéa abies mais
c'est une variétés horticoles men et
celui ci a maintenant 30 ans du plus
petit au plus grand l'arboretum abrite
plusieurs séquoia américain planté entre
1922 et 1925
c'est l'espèce la plus grosse du monde
quand on compte sur volume de troncs
sont que des arbres qui peuvent
atteindre 95 mètres dans la nature alors
ici on a des arbres qui font simplement
une petite vingtaine trentaine de mètres
ils sont vraiment des petits jeunes
parce que c'est des arbres qui peut
vivre plusieurs milliers d'années
l'arboretum abrite également depuis 1982
2000 m² de serres le site regroupe 5000
plants et fait partie des quatre plus
grandes structures de ce type en ile de
france
ici on reconstitue des climats tropicaux
sec et aride tempérée ou des jungles
luxuriantes
ils ont toutes les conditions pour
donner le la
leur puissance c'est-à-dire chaleur
humidité les lumières donc à partir de
ce moment là vous avez une explosion une
explosion de la végétation qui est digne
de son nom son biotope d'origine
seuls des petits groupes visiter les
serres chaque mois sur inscription les
plantes sont principalement utilisé pour
les recherches ou pour fournir des sites
parisiens ici faivre luz et 90% des
collections végétales du jardin des
plantes de paris donc il ya constamment
des échanges qui se font des plantes
qu'on met à maturité ici et qu'on envoie
après dans les grandes serres du jardin
des plantes de paris
mais certains trésors sont conservées
précieusement ici c'est le cas de ce
cactus qu'on retrouve seulement
l'amérique centrale et dans la
cordillère des andes
c'est une très belle à agave qui a en
reflet de un peu gris bleuté
un volume assez exceptionnel elle attire
l'oeil d'une façon assez extraordinaire
il s'y plaît aussi à la preuve c'est
qu'il a trouvé sa place et il est tout à
fait adapté à notre climat verfaillie
sous protection en 2018 l'arboretum de
versailles chèvreloup a attiré près de
23 mille visiteurs du mois d'avril à
novembre
un trésor du patrimoine libinois encore
cachées qui gagne à se faire connaître